when you think of an image you kind of
dream it up first
there is no difference in how i approach
making an assignment like a vogue cover
or a personal shoot
i fixate on an idea
[Music]
and then i go out and make my idea
happen
[Music]
in this class i'm going to be discussing
what i do when i make portraits of
subjects in natural light
i'll be walking through how i compose my
photos
and essentially all the ingredients that
go into the recipe of making pictures
for my early work the camera that i used
was a camera that i borrowed from my
friend
you don't need expensive gear to make
beautiful photography
whatever you can get your hands on i
would suggest to try even your phone
with what you have in your pocket it is
very possible to make something striking
and to tell a story
gorgeous it's important to be adaptable
to whatever kind of sunlight conditions
you get
and to work with it and not against it
that's nice
with film it's a very patient process
you're not trying to just like
shoot shoot shoot that's nice there hold
that
to tell your own stories it's important
to think about your experiences
in your life i mainly want to see
protagonists
both look like me and be experiencing a
certain freedom in public space
so when i make images of friends hula
hooping or
enjoying seemingly mundane pleasures
it's about
thinking about freedom that i wish for
them and for myself
the most important thing to do is to
continue making pictures
and to share them online that's been the
main way through which people have been
able to engage with my work to see what
i'm up to
there are no rules to this okay suppress
those feelings of self-doubt
that's perfect the main thing that you
should follow is what excites you
what inspires you and your personal
sensibilities
now ask yourself what kind of stories do
i want to tell
i'm tyler mitchell and this is my master
[Music]
class
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you